you're simply the best
classic tina tana
but um celine dion is also down the
cover of the song but we won't be
talking about celine today but selenium
because a new study has come out that i
think you'll find interesting
so selenium then the chemical element
that is essential for our bodies
this is because selenium is used in
selenium-containing proteins of which we
have 25 genes for in humans
these genes are important for
development and also include proteins
involved in redox homeostasis
so controlling oxidation and reduction
reactions
so how can a protein contain selenium
well they contain at least one amino
acids the building blocks of protein
known as selenocysteine
cysteine is one of the 20 different
amino acids used by our cell
but instead of having the sulfur residue
as found in cysteine
selenocysteine instead has selenium
and so i guess technically there are
more than 20 different amino acids
but selenocysteine is pretty rare in
relative terms compared to the other
amino acids but that doesn't mean it's
most important
so where does selenium come from
well we can get selenium from our diet
selenium is found in foods like oysters
brazil nuts eggs tuna sunflower seeds
and mushrooms
the current recommended dietary
allowance for humans is 55 micrograms
which might sound a bit low but selenium
toxicity can occur at levels above 400
micrograms
it has been previously shown in mice
that dietary selenium levels regulate
the expression of selenium proteins
which also make sense as you can't make
these saline proteins if you're
deficient in selenium
but they also saw in a study that
altering the intake of selenium didn't
impact mal's lifespan
but the story doesn't end here
and that's because i like brazil nuts
and tuna and when i'm not recovering
from a bike injury i also like to go
running and while exercise in general
has been known to have neurogenesis
enhancing effects but how exactly
well it's commonly known that exercise
results in the systemic release of many
factors into the blood which can be
sensed by neural stem cells in the brain
the question is determining which of
these factors are important and relevant
to the offense
so in this recent publication they did
proteomics of mouse blood plasma from
either mice that were kept in a cage
compared to mice that had access to a
running wheel for four days
and out of 68 proteins that changed
significantly in the mice with the
running wheel selenium protein p was the
most significantly upregulated
so i was hinted at by the name celino
protein p is indeed a selenium protein
the unique feature about this selenium
protein though is that it actually
contains 10 selenocystine residues
whilst the others appear to just carry
one
so could this be the cause for increased
neurogenesis
well to notice for sure you have to
uncover the molecular mechanism so
that's what they did
and so firstly they questioned whether
selenium alone could cause neurogenesis
they infused sodium selenide a
water-soluble salt of selenium into the
hippocampus of the mice for seven days
and then looked to see if there were
signs of cell replication
in the dentate gyrus a region adjacent
to the hippocampus and known to contain
neural precast cells
they saw a three-fold increase in the
number of proliferating cells following
this increase in selenium
this region of the brain is also
involved in episodic memory and
exploration of novel environments so it
was therefore validating to see that old
mice here 16 months old that were given
50 nanomolar selenium in drinking water
for 8 weeks performed better and
different spatial learning tasks such as
the bronze maze where mice have to use
visual clues to locate the escape
chamber
so let's come back to saline protein p
how would that work
well there are receptors on brain
capillary endothelial cells called lrp8
which recognize saline protein p and
aids selenium transport across the
blood's brain barrier though exactly how
this is done seems a little bit unclear
to me
but anyway in line with this idea mice
with lrp8
mice without lrp8 showed a significant
reduction in neurogenesis following
exercise compared to the controls
so to summarize all of these findings so
far the authors have generated this
figure
selenium or running mediates an increase
in neurogenesis and adult mice
the former mechanism involves both
selenoprotein p and lrp8 and this
increased neurogenesis is correlated
with improvements in spatial memory
there are clearly some questions that
remain to be addressed
where is the selenium protein p coming
from for example
it's thought that this protein is mainly
expressed in the liver but it could in
theory come from other cell types too
selena protein p is also just one out of
many factors that are upregulated during
exercise and others include cathepsin b
bdnf and fedjaf
so do these factors synergize together
to promote neurogenesis
so what are my thoughts well
i'm a runner and i like exercise and i
think that it comes with many benefits
probably beyond an increase in celino
protein p alone
however what this study demonstrates is
that we can use selenium to tease apart
the molecular mechanism linking exercise
to neurogenesis
however it is worth mentioning that i
think there appears to be a goldilocks
effect with selenium
like how too much or too little exercise
could be bad so can too much or too
little selenium
as deficiency or excess selenium levels
have been linked to a variety of chronic
health issues including type 2 diabetes
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease and
depression
so what can you take from this study
well to quote from this article we could
start thinking about selenium as a
strategy to treat or prevent cognitive
decline in those who cannot exercise or
are more vulnerable to selenium
deficiency
such as older adults and stroke and
alzheimer's disease patients
and added support for this comes from
the fact that celium is a cheap readily
available dietary supplement
and is found in many commonly eaten
foods so it could easily be implemented
into a diet
and so one thing that i think would also
be interesting to test is if you can
remember back to the start of the video
where i showed that selenium
supplementation didn't increase my
lifespan
would be to test whether a higher
selenium diet increases their lifespan
of alzheimer's disease miles models
as potentially and i am being quite
hypothetical here one of the reasons why
normal mice didn't seem to have an
increased lifespan with selenium could
be due to the fact that mice have never
been a pretty good model for
neurodegeneration
and so maybe there really could be some
therapeutic potential to selenium
supplementation and an experiment like
this might help us to address that
question
but anyway it seems risky to be either
too low or too high regarding selenium
levels but it might be something that
you want to ponder on next time you eat
some fish or munch on some brazil nuts
so with that i hope you've learned
something in this video thank you to my
patreon supporters and thank you for
listening
you